ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนเดี๋ยวขอกู้หญิงเขียนวันที่อ่ะนะคะ
ตายห่าวน่าจะโอเค
แป๊บนึงนะคะไม่ค่อยเข้าใจสู่
เดี๋ยวทำให้ครูใหญ่ก่อน
โอเคค่ะ
อย่างนิดนึงไม่รู้เห็นแค่ไหนอ่ะโอเค Good
ไม่คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันที่วัน
อังคารครับนี้คุณนิคเห็นเนาะอีกที่ก็ยัง
เขียนครับเป็นเข้าวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คนเมื่อ
มาดูออกวันที่ 14 ครับเอาที่ 14 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับเดือนมิถุนายนปีพ
ตอะไรคะดีผช
2565 ครับ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ครับค่ะ
2022 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิตอนนี้
ที่อเมริกาที่คุณนิดอยู่นะครับเวลา
แปดโมง 13 นาทีค่ะค่ะ
8 โมง 13 นาทีชายแล้วที่ถ่ายทัพตอนนี้
กี่โมงตอนนี้กูหญิงไม่ได้อยู่ไทยค่ะคืนดิ
เอ้าหรอค่ะอ่ะ
ค่ะเพลงข้างหลังเหมือนกับอยู่ที่ไทย
เหมือนเดิม
ได้ดูเหมือนเดิม
เอาตอนนี้อยู่ที่ไหนครับตอนนี้ก็กูหญิง
อยู่อเมริกาเหมือนครูนิคค่ะอ๋อแล้วโอเค
ตอนดีที่ครูหญิงอยู่กี่โมงครับพรุ่งนี้
ที่ครูหญิงอยู่เนี่ยก็อ้าวเป็นค่ะ
9:00 น 13 นาทีค่ะครูนิดตอนเช้าขอ
โอเคเร็วกว่าครูนิ 1 ชั่วโมงโอเคคุณนี้
คุณอีกเดาว่าผู้หญิงอยู่ทางขวาของอเมริกา
ใช่ไหมครับ
ห่างได้ตะวันออกเพราะว่าใช่ใช่เออใช่ๆค่ะ
ผู้หญิงอยู่ผู้หญิงอยู่ฝั่งตะวันออกของ
อเมริกา
ทำไมครูนิครู้เพราะว่าที่อเมริกานะมัน
ใหญ่แล้วถ้าเวลาเร็วกว่าครูนิดเนี่ยก็จะ
มาจากทางตะวันออก
ตะวันตกเวลาเขาจะช้ากว่าคนนี้ค่ะขอบคุณ
ที่ได้อยู่ตรงกลางๆอยู่ที่นี่ๆๆใช่คนที่
อยู่ตรงกลางก็เลยรู้ว่าอ้อโอเคครับจ่าย
ค่ะจริงๆตอน
ตอนไม่ถึงกับว่าต้องมาอเมริกาเนาะตอนที่
รู้จักประเทศอเมริกาว่าเมื่อก่อนทำงาน
เป็นครูใช่ไหมคะคุณนี้ก็มีนักเรียนเนี่ย
เป็นคนอเมริกาเยอะแล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยก็มา
จากหลายๆรัฐในอเมริกา
มาแล้วนั้นเลยก็บอกว่าเวลาแต่ละรัฐเนี่ย
ไม่ตรงกัน
เราอ่ะเป็นคนไทยเราก็รู้สึกว่าเอาทำไม
อยู่ประเทศเดียวกันเวลาไม่เหมือนกันคือ
เออ
ใช่ก็คิดว่าใน a ในเอเชียครับมีหลายที่
ที่ก็ทั้งประเทศเวลาเหมือนกัน
เราเวลาไปประเทศที่มันใหญ่เหมือนอเมริกา
หรือออสเตรเลียเวลาก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะครับ
ค่ะเขาเพราะว่ามันประเทศมันกว้างใช่ไหมคะ
มากใช่มันก็ไม่เหมือนกันจริงๆคุณนิดจำได้
ว่าที่ที่ในเอเชียนะเอ่อ
อินโดนีเซีย Indonesia เนี่ย
เวลาไม่เหมือนกัน
เพราะมันจะมีเหมือนอย่างจะกัดอ้าเวลาจะ
เหมือนที่ไทยถ้าคุณนิคมาแล้วทางด้านขวา
ของประเทศตะวันออกนะครับจะเร็วกว่า 1
ชั่วโมง
อยู่นี่ๆอันนั้นก็เหมือนจะลดประเทศเดียว
กันเวลาไม่เหมือนกัน
จะเชื่อมงามอันใหญ่มากชายๆตอนนั้นก็งง
เอ๊ะทำไม
สัตว์คิดว่าอะไรก็เลยคิดว่าอ๋อถ้าเรามี
เพื่อนแล้วอยู่คนละที่ที่เวลาไม่เหมือน
กันเวลาจะนัดคุยกันก็ต้องบอกนะว่าโอเคนะ
8 โมงเช้าเวลาชั้นใช่
เครื่องก็จะงงอีกว่าเอ๊ะแล้วเวลาเธอเนี่ย
อยู่ที่ไหน
เราโอโอ้มันงงเหมือนกันนะใช่เพราะว่าเรา
ว่าเราชินกับที่ในเวลาเดียวในประเทศใช่
มากแต่ที่เมียเขาบอกว่าตามรัฐก็จริงแต่
ว่ามันไม่ใช่ว่า 50 รัฐ 50 เวลาคือเหมือน
กันแหละเป็นช่องว่า 4 ถ้าจำไม่ผิดน่าจะ 4
4 เวลามั้งครับว่าตะวันตกเลยอย่างที่
อาโทโอ้หรือแถวชายฝั่งพวกแคลิฟอร์เนียอัน
นั้นน่ะเขาก็จะช้ากว่าที่คุณนิคอยู่ 2
ชั่วโมง
หากขยับมานิดนึงก็จะช้ากว่าคุณนิดหนึ่ง
ชั่วโมงต้องชายแบบนี้ครับมันเข้าก็จะมี
เพราะว่าของคู่นี้เนี่ยเขาจะคิดว่าเป็น
เวลาเขาจะคิดว่าเป็นเวลาตรงกลางชายเหมือน
เขาจะเรียกว่าเป็น Central  Time แบบนี้
มันก็จะมีชื่อเรียกไม่เหมือนกันใช่ค่ะผู้
หญิงเคยเคยดูคืนมาดูทีวีในอเมริกานะเคยไป
นอนโรงแรมที่กรุงเทพฯน่ะค่ะแล้วโรงแรม
เนี่ยก็มีรายการทีวีเราก็ดูทีวีแล้วก็
เหมือนมีโปรแกรมของซีรีส์หรืออะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแล้วเขาก็พูดว่าอ๋อ
ซีรีส์เรื่องนี้เนี่ยเราจะดูได้วันอังคาร
20:00 นแล้วก็พูดเวลาเหมือนเส้นคำถาม
Eastern ค่ะกูอยู่จำไม่ได้ว่าอะไรอ่ะแต่
เราอ่ะนั้นใช่เราก็คืออะไรอ่ะใช่เราก็งง
มากทำไมต้องมีแบบนี้
แต่ว่าพกทีวีแบบนั้นน่ะคูนิจำได้ว่าตอนไป
สิงคโปร์
สิงคโปร์ก็มีเหมือนกันพวกรายการทีวีเพราะ
ว่าเหมือนกับบางรายการเขาช้าเขาเขาฉายเขา
ออกทีวีทั้งสิงคโปร์และอินโดนีเซีย
ขอขอบพระสมโอเคมันเป็นช่องเดียวที่ฉาย 2
ประเทศเขาก็จะบอกโอเคเวลานี้ของประเทศนี้
เวลานี้ของประเทศนี้เพราะเวลาไม่ตรงกัน
[เพลง]
คือ
ด้วยความที่เราเป็นคนไทยเนาะประเทศไทยของ
เราเนี่ยเหมือนทุกอย่างอยู่ตรงกลางก็คือ
กรุงเทพฯใช่หน้าซื่อกรุงเทพฯเป็นแบบไหน
หลายๆที่ในประเทศไทยก็เหมือนกันไว้แต่
อย่างอเมริกาเขาเป็นประเทศใหญ่
50 รัฐทุกรัฐเหมือนดูแลตัวเองอ่ะคือไม่
แวะไปไม่ได้ฟังอ่าวอชิงตันดีซีอย่างเดียว
ใช่ๆเขาก็จะดูแลตัวเองพูดถึงทีวีเมื่อ
ก่อนนะคุณนิดดีขึ้นเช็คอ้ะไม่รู้ว่าตอน
นี้คุณนี้ก็ยังไม่แน่ใจเพราะว่าเคยเคยตอน
สมัยเรียนที่มหาลัยเนาะคุณนี้ก็
กูนี้ก็อยากดูอยากดูก็ซีรีส์ฝรั่งแล้วเขา
ก็บอกว่าโอเคซีรีส์นี้ฉายเวลานี้ออกทีวี
เวลานี้
20:00 นจะขึ้นเพราะที่อเมริกาเนี่ยเวลา
มันไม่เหมือนกันคุณนิดอยากดูรู้เป็นคนแรก
คนให้เกินเฮ้อไอ้กับเข้าอินเตอร์เน็ตไปดู
ว่าฝั่งตะวันตกมันเดียวนะสั่งตะวันออกจาก
เร็วที่สุดก็ไปดูตรงนั้นก่อนเพื่อที่รู้
ก่อนคนจากฝั่งหรืออื่นๆเพราะว่ามันเสียง
ทุ่มก่อนใช่มั้ยฝั่งตะวันออกเนี่ยสองทุ่ม
ก่อนคนฝั่งตะวันออกก็ต้องได้ดูก่อน
ก็ได้จะได้คุยนี้ก็คิดแบบนั้นแต่จริงๆมัน
ไม่ใช่ก็เราคุยกันก็คิดเหมือนกูนี่นะเออ
คือจริงๆมันเหมือนกับว่าเพราะว่าเขาบอก
แล้วเป็นเวลานี้ 20:00 นสั่งตะวันออกแต่
คุณนิคตอนนั้นน่ะก็คิดว่าตะวันออกมันก็
เหมือนกันทั้งประเทศ
ไอ้เพราะว่า 20:00 นตะวันออกก็แปลว่าที่
ตะวันตกเขาก็จะฉายแบบ 16:00 นขออะไรรู้
เหมือนกันขอคือได้ดูพร้อมกันให้ใช่แต่แค่
แต่ละที่เนี่ยที่กับเป็นเส้นเวลาหน้าที่
คุณนี่บอกว่าน่าจะประมาณ 4 เวลาใช่ไหมคะ
แค่แต่ละที่ดูดูในเวลาไม่เหมือนกันนะ
คุณนี่ก็เข้าใจผิดอันนั้นน่ะมันก็เป็น
เหมือนกับคนไทยก็พูดเหมือนกันนะว่ามันจะ
เป็นตัวใช้ว่าเป็นเคาท์เตอร์ Shop นิด
หน่อยไหมอ่ะแต่มันเป็นอะไรที่เราไม่ชิน
กับที่เราเคยอยู่ใช่ค่ะคิดว่าแบบตรงเนาะ
ใจ
ใส่ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าอาจจะใช้ได้ว่าเออเป็น
เขาจะชอบเพราะว่าแต่ว่ามันอาจจะไม่ได้แบบ
ช็อกมากตกใจมากเพราะว่ามันแต่มันก็ไม่
เหมือนกันไงเราก็จะรู้สึกแบบทำไม
[เพลง]
เรา
อ๋อถ้าจะไม่ผิดครูหญิงเคยบอกว่าอันนี้คือ
ไปที่อเมริกาครั้งแรกใช่ไหมครับ
คิดครั้งนี้เหรอๆทำไมไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่แบบผู้หญิงมาครั้งแรกเนี่ยน่าจะปี
2017 น้าไก่คิดว่านะคิดว่าน่าจะ 2,000  7
แล้วผู้หญิงเคยเธออะไรที่ถ้าเป็นเขาเจอ
ช็อปที่ครูหญิงตกใจไหมผู้หญิงเนี่ยตกใจ
มากๆแล้วก็แบบว่าเป็นอ้าวคิดว่าเป็นเขาจะ
ช็อคมากๆก็คือห้องน้ำค่ะครูเล็กห้องน้ำใน
อเมริกาแต่ไม่ใช่ว่าห้องน้ำที่อเมริกา
เนี่ยไม่มีสายฉีดนะคือห้องน้ำที่ประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยนะคะมันมันจะมีสายฉีดผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ดาวน์โหลดรูปเอาไว้แต่ว่ามันได้มันหายนะ
คะอ๋อ
หน้าคือห้องน้ำในไทยและมันจะมีสายฉีดใช่
ไหมคะแต่ที่อ่าหลายๆประเทศเนี่ยไม่มีแบบ
นี้นะคะนักเรียนนี่ไม่ใช่อาบน้ำนะคะเวลา
ที่เราเข้าห้องน้ำเสร็จแล้วมันจะมีสาย
สำหรับฉีดหน้าซึ่งเนี้ยเรารู้แล้วว่าเรา
เคยสอนนักเรียนที่เป็นคนต่างชาติใช่ไหม
เราก็ไม่ได้ตกใจอะไรแต่เวลามาที่อเมริกา
ก็จะตกใจที่ว่าแบบเหมือนห้องน้ำอันมี
ประตูแล้วเวลาเราปิดประตูแล้วเนี่ยมันจะ
มีช่องว่างช่องว่างของประตูค่ะที่แบบ
มันยังไม่มากอ้ะ
นักเรียนน่าจะเข้าใจแล้วว่าสมมติสมมติตรง
นี้เป็นเป็นประตูห้องน้ำ
นะรายการนี้เป็นห้องน้ำอีกห้องหนึ่ง
แล้วก็เป็นห้องน้ำอีกห้องหนึ่งใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ตรงเนี้ยะเนี่ยมันจะเป็นช่อง
ระหว่างประตูที่เรารู้สึกว่าเออมันกว้าง
มากๆอ่ะค่ะ
ทั้งๆและข้างล่างตรงนี้นี้เป็นพื้นครับ
ข้างล่างนี่ก็กว้างมากแล้วครูหญิงก็เป็น
คนตัวเตี้ย
เวลามีคนเดินผ่านอ้ะเค้ากินทั้งหมดเป็น
ผู้หญิงเหมือนกันนะว่าเป็นห้องน้ำผู้หญิง
อยู่แล้วแต่ว่าเวลาสิ่งที่เราเห็นผู้หญิง
หรือว่าคนเดินผ่านเราคิดเขาเห็นเราหรือ
เปล่าอ่ะเพราะว่าเราเห็นขาเขาแบบคือ
เหมือนคุณก็จะเห็นขาเขาเออเขาใหญ่ไปเนาะ
ค่ะอ่าได้ขาคนใช่ไหมราชายๆผสมปิงก็จะเห็น
ขาเขาแบบประมาณนี้เลยอ่ะอันนี้ก็คือคน
เนาะคนที่ป่ะเออเขาเดินผ่านเราเรารู้สึก
แบบทำไมห้องน้ำมันกว้างมากอ่ะแล้วแบบช่อง
ช่องระหว่างประตูมันก็กว้างพอที่เราจะมอง
เห็นคนที่เข้าห้องน้ำอยู่ข้างในมันก็เลย
เป็นอะไรที่เรารู้สึกว่า
ตกใจมากๆมาเป็นสิ่งที่แบบ
พวกนี้นะคะครั้งนี้เนี่ยมาน่าจะประมาณ
ครั้งที่
144 ก็ยังรู้สึกแบบยังตกใจอยู่อ่ะเกี่ยว
กับห้องน้ำหรือว่าช่องว่างตรงประตูผู้
หญิงคิดว่าเอ่อคนไทยหลายๆคนที่มาอเมริกา
เรื่องช่องว่างระหว่างประตูของห้องน้ำที่
มันกว้างมากๆน่าจะเป็นเรื่องเขาจะช็อค
อันดับแรกๆอ่ะอ่าใช่จริงๆคนในก็คุณในก็
เห็นด้วยนะเพราะว่าตอนแรกๆคนนิดมาคืนนี้
ก็ตกใจเหมือนกันเพราะคุณนิตชินกับที่ถ่าย
ในที่ที่มันก็ติดมันไม่มีช่องว่างเลยว่าง
ก็ถ้ามีในห้างมันก็จะชอบนิดเดียวเอาจะเอา
กระดาษทิชชู่เข้าไปได้ใช่ค่ะเอาคู่นี้
เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าเพราะอะไรแต่คู่นิดเดาคิด
ว่าเป็นเรื่องของความปลอดภัยว่า
ถ้ามีใครเป็นอะไรคนข้างนอกเขาเห็นได้เอา
อ๋ออาจจะดูว่ามีคนอยู่ไหมจะได้เปิดประตู
เข้าไปชายจะเหมาะกันๆแล้วจะเป็นช่องว่างๆ
ได้มึงคิดอย่างนั้นนะใช่จากแล้วก็อีก
อย่างนึงเนี่ยคุณอันนี้ถ้าเริ่มส่วนตัว
คุณคิดว่าคนไทยอ่ะจะชินว่ากลัวว่าคนจะมอง
มันก็เลยปิดหมดงานแล้วทีเนี้ยก็ไปอเมริกา
มันช่องมันว่างก็เลิกจะนั้นทำยังไงถ้าทำ
อะไรจะมีคนมองมั้ยสวัสดีคนสมองเราหรือ
เปล่า
เราอ่ะไม่ชินเออเพราะว่าแบบจริงๆคนต่าง
ประเทศนะหรือว่าคนอเมริกาคนยุโรปเนี้ยเขา
ก็ไม่ค่อยไม่ค่อยมองคนอื่นใช่มันไม่ใช่
มองว่าเขาไม่ค่อยสนใจคนอื่นมากเท่าคนไทยๆ
ๆ
คนไทยคนไทยจะมีชื่อเหมือนไทยมุงอยู่แล้ว
ไงแล้วก็
สายๆเราจะรู้สึกแบบน่าสนใจอะไรเงี้ยอะ
อย่างครูหญิงหรือว่าครูนิคอย่างเงี้ยอยู่
อเมริกาใช่ไหมคะเราก็จะไม่เหมือนคน
อเมริกาแต่มันเราก็จะไม่เจอคนที่มองเรา
มากๆใช่อ่าชายเดี๋ยว *  *  x จะมีรูปให้
ดูอันนี้เวลาเข้าห้องน้ำผู้ชายเนาะจะมี
แบบนี้ที่ออสเตรเลียที่คุณเคยอยู่เนี่ย
แบบนี้ในห้องน้ำผู้ชายเยอะมากแล้วครั้ง
แรกที่คุณนี้เข้าไปเนี่ยพรุ่งนี้ก็ไม่ชิน
กูนึกว่าแป้ะแล้วจะทำยังไงเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้
เป็นหน้าเป็นเวลาผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำแล้ว
เขาจะยืนเนาะค่ะกินเข้าห้องน้ำเดี๋ยวคุย
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำไม่
เหมือนกันนะอันนี้อะไรคะคุณนิคเนี่ยคือ
เวลาเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วเขาก็ยืน
ยืนฉี่แบบนี้แหละหมอฉี่ผู้ชายใช่ที่
ออสเตรเลียได้เขาก็จะยืนกันหลายๆคนที
เดียวเลยนะแล้วไม่มีที่กันเถอะเพราะคนไทย
อ่ะก็อย่างน้อยก็จะมีแบบแยกอ่าน 2 อัน
ห่างนิดหน่อยหรือ EM อะไรกั้นไม่ให้เห็น
จบแบบนี้ครับเที่ยวเซเลียเป็นแบบนี้
แล้วตอนครูนิเข้าไปในห้องน้ำที่
ออสเตรเลียครั้งแรกแล้วเห็นโถฉี่ผู้ชาย
เป็นแบบนี้ตอนนั้นคุณเอ็กซ์คิดคิดไม่คะ
ว่ามันคืออะไรคุณญากาศรู้ว่ามันเป็นโถฉี่
แต่ครูนี้ก็คิดว่าแล้วจะทำยังไง
อันนี้เนี่ยคนที่ว่ามันมันมันแปลกสำหรับ
คุณคุณนี้ก็จะมาลบก็ไปยืนข้างๆกับเขาเลย
หรอคนที่เขายืนแล้วมันมีที่ว่างแล้วก็ไป
เบียดแล้วก็ขอ 4 หน่อยซึ่งคำเดียวหรอเออ
แต่เราว่าไม่ชินเพราะว่าอย่างนี้น่าจะยืน
ได้ประมาณ
7-8 คนเลยมั้งหรือ 5-6 เธอเธอยุ่งๆน่ะ
เขาก็เบียดกันแล้วก็
ยืนฉี่แบบนี้เลย
แค่นี้ประเทศไทยก็ไม่ก็คือไม่เคยเห็นนะ
เวลาเปิดคำว่าห้องน้ำในประเทศไทยเออพวก
คุณนี้ก็คิดว่ายังไม่เห็นคู่นี้เคยเห็น
ตามร้านอาหารแบบหมูกระทะที่เคนอาหารแบบ
บ้านๆนะเขาก็รู้จะเยอะๆใช่ไหมค่ะจัดคือ
แบบนี้เขายังมีมันเป็นเหล็กกันมันก็ยัง
เอกตามปั๊มน้ำมันต่างจังหวัดคุณนิเคยเห็น
แต่มันไม่ได้โล่งแบบนี้มันเป็นเกือบไม่มี
อะไรกันเลยไม่มีอะไรมากอ่ะ
5 แบบต่างประเทศพระอาจารย์ไม่ได้รู้สึก
ว่าแบบเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วมันต้องส่วนตัวมี
ขนาดนั้น
คนไทยจะรู้สึกว่าเข้าห้องน้ำมันจะส่วนตัว
แบบไม่อยากให้ใครเนี่ยเห็นว่าเรากำลังทำ
อะไรอยู่ในห้องน้ำใช่แต่คือคนคนต่างชาติ
เนี่ยทางตะวันตกกับคุณนี้คิดว่าเขามองว่า
ก็เป็นเรื่องธรรมดาเขาไม่สนใจคนอื่นเขา
ไม่รู้สึกไอ่ใช่ใช่อีกอย่างนึงเกี่ยวกับ
ห้องน้ำเนี่ยเพราะว่าคุณนี้ก็จำได้ว่าเคย
ไปว่ายน้ำที่มีตอนนั้นไปหาที่สาวที่
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์เราก็ตอนนั้นคนที่ก็ประมาณ
มหาวิทยาลัยครับอายุ 17 ประมาณ 18-19
คุณนี้ก็ไปเข้าห้องน้ำเนี่ยแหละเหมือนกับ
ว่าว่ายน้ำเสร็จแล้วก็เข้าห้องน้ำเป็น
ห้องอาบน้ำใหญ่กับคือคุณนี้ก็ตกใจก็เพราะ
ว่าทุกคนผู้ชายในห้องน้ำในห้องอาบน้ำ
เนี่ยเขาไม่มีผ้าเช็ดตัวเขาก็เดินแบบไม่
ใส่เสื้อผ้าเลยใช่โล่งโด่งๆเลยเดินแบบไม่
รู้สึกอะไรไม่อายเหมือนอย่างคนไทยที่ต้อง
มีอะไรปิดเอ่อให้เขาก็ทำเป็นเรื่องปกติ 3
เราอ่ะโดนเขามองว่าแกลบเพราะเป็นคนเดียว
ที่ไปเพื่อชาติเออเนี่ยมันก็เป็นเรื่อง
เขาเจอร์ช็อปเป็นอะไรที่เราเนี่ยเห็น
ครั้งแรกแล้วก็
ทำไมอ่ะเออแล้วเรารับคนนี้คิดนะตอนนั้น
ว่าเดี๋ยวเราจะต้องถอดถ้าออกด้วยให้
เหมือนคนอื่นแต่เราจะได้ไม่แปลกปั่นตอน
นั้นคุญนี้เกิดไม่ได้อ้ะมันไม่ชี้
ใช่คือทำไมมันก็มันก็ตลกดีขอรบกวนนึกย้อน
กลับไปเทิงเธอแต่วัฒนธรรมเขาอ่ะมันเป็น
แบบนั้นเขาบอกว่าก็ไม่มีอะไรปิดห้องน้ำ
เราเข้าห้องน้ำมันก็ต้องโล่งโจ้ง
โรงเลยเอาเป็นเรื่องปกติของการเที่ยวจะ
เข้าห้องน้ำไปอาบน้ำ
ใช่คนคนไทยก็อาจจะมองว่าเป็นเรื่องแบบ
เห้ยอายเจอฉันไม่คนไทยอายุรู้สึกแบบใน
ห้องน้ำเป็นอะไรที่แบบเราต้องส่วนตัวว่า
คนจะมาเห็นไม่ใช่
นั่นแหละมันก็เลยเป็นเหมือนสิ่งที่ไม่
เหมือนกันพอเราไปเห็นไปเจอในประเทศอื่น
ที่ไม่เหมือนประเทศเราที่เราไม่ชินไงมัน
อาจจะเป็นแบบเออเค้าเจอช็อคนิดหน่อยนะ
จริงๆมันก็มีหลายอย่างเนาะที่เขาจะของของ
ที่คุณเคยเจอว่าเออมันก็แปลกเวลาละมาต่าง
อาศยานก็เป็นเรื่องที่ชื่อว่าน่าจะเป็น
เรื่องแปลกที่คุณบอกแล้วว่าตกใจตกใจใช่
ค่ะเป็นน่าจะเป็นเรื่องห้องน้ำแล้วผู้
หญิงก็คิดว่าเวลานักเรียนมาประเทศไทยแล้ว
มาเข้าห้องน้ำในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันจะตกใจ
เหมือนกันก็ได้ก็ไม่เหมือนกันไงเรายังไป
ตกใจในประเทศนักเรียนเลยใช่ใช่โอเคเอ่อ
โอเคค่ะก็วันนี้เราก็มาเล่าให้ฟังเกี่ยว
กับเขาจะช็อคในห้องน้ำแล้วกันเนาะเกี่ยว
กับห้องน้ำเนี่ยที่เราเคยเจอเป็นห้องน้ำ
เลยนะคะคุณดิเออโอเค
บ่ายค่ะนักเรียนเคยมาประเทศไทยแล้วเข้า
ห้องน้ำที่ประเทศไทยแล้วตกใจอะไร
เหมือนเราเคยเจอในต่างประเทศหรือเปล่าก็
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะหายๆโอเคได้วันนี้ก็
เวลาหมดใช้งานเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะโอเคครับเจอกันใหม่สวัสดี
ครับ
ม.ค